[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات مدن
وعواصم في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث
مميزه
البدايه من رام الله واجواء توتر بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله بسبب تصعيد قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقرار بنفير تجديد الاجراءات
ضد الاسرى الفلسطينيين
وهذه الصور من نيامي عاصمه النيجر ومن
محيط القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه تحديدا
بعد مظاهرات مناهضه للوجود العسكري
والدبلوماسيه الفرنسي
والى كيف عاصمه اوكرانيا حيث تم الاعلان
عن نجاح تجربه لصاروخ باليستي محلي سنه
بمدى الف كيلومتر
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
اسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه وتجديد
للاجراءات على الاسرى قوه الاحتلال تقتل
شابا فلسطينيا في طوباس وتقر باخفاقها في
اعتقاد احد المطلوبين وخلاف علني بين
بنكير ونتنياهو بشان تقليص زيارات اهالي
الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال
اوكرانيا تعلن نجاح اختبار صاروخ البالستي
يبلغ مداه الف كيلو متر روسيا تؤكد
استهداف نظام التحكم الالكتروني
الاستراتيجي للجيش الاوكراني والتدمير
مصانع للطائرات المسيره واشنطن تؤكد انها
لا تشجعوا على تنفيذ هجمات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه
يشددون على ان وضع السفير الفرنسي غير
قانوني ويامرون بتنفيذ قرار ترحيله ماكرون
يؤكد انه على اتصال يومي مع الرئيس
المحتجز محمد بازوم ويشدد على ان القرارات
التي تتخذها فرنسا بشان النيجر ستتم بناء
على المحادثات مع بازون
بعد تعليق عضويه الجابون الاتحاد الافريقي
يفوض جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى القيام
بالوساطه المجموعه الاقتصاديه لوسط
افريقيا
تطالب بعوده النظام الدستوري وقاده
الانقلاب يعقدون لقاءات مع سياسيين ورجال
اعمال محليين
ويتعهدون بمحاربه الفساد
في لقاءنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم تشديده وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي وزير الامن اتمار
للاجراءات ضد الاسرى الفلسطينيين في سجون
الاحتلال
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي والسؤال
يقول ما هي التداعيات المحتمله لاحدث
حلقات التجديد على الاسرى الفلسطينيه
الاجابات جاءت على النحو التالي
47% قالوا ان التداعيات هي مزيد من الغضب
الفلسطيني في مواجهه الاحتلال
بينما فضل عشرون بالمئه القول بوجود
تداعيات تتمثل في انقسامات حكوميه
اسرائيليه بسبب قرارات
واخيرا صوت
33% لصالح خيار تصعيد اشكال الاحتجاج في
صفوف الاسرى الفلسطينيين
هذا السؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيه ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
[موسيقى]
حرائق اليونان تتواصل والسلطات تنبه سكان
مناطق حدوديه لاجلاء محتمل
[موسيقى]
اقتحام اسرائيلي جديد في الضفه الغربيه
قبل بوابل من الرصاص فصائل المقاومه فقد
افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال
انسحبت من بلده طوباس بعد ان فشلت في
اعتقال احد المطلوبين عقب محاصره بيته وهو
ما اقرت به اذاعه جيش الاحتلال ووسط
اشتباكات مع مقاومين في البلده استهدفت
قوات الاحتلال بقذيفه صاروخيه احد المنازل
ما الحق به اضرارا بالغا هذا واعلنت كتيبه
طوباس التابعه لسرايا القدس ان مقاتليها
اشتبكوا مع قوات الاحتلال على محاور عده
داخل القريه كما اعلنت كتائب القسام
تصديها للهجوم وتحرير الفلسطيني احمد ابو
عره من منزله المحاصر
هذا وقد شيع اهالي بلده عقابه في مدينه
طوباس بالضفه الغربيه جثمان الشهيد عبد
الرحيم غنام الذي توفي متاثرا بجراحا اصيب
بها صباح اليوم خلال اقتحام جيش الاحتلال
البلده بهدف اعتقال مطلوبين
وردد المشيعون هتافات وشعارات تندد بجرائم
الاحتلال وتؤكد مساندتهم
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وينضم الينا من الناصره الدكتور سليم بريق
الخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي والمحاذر في
العلوم السياسيه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور
هذا التصدي هذا التصدي من قبل المقاومين
لمقام به جيش الاحتلال اليوم كيف يمكن ان
يقرا
مساء الخير طبعا نحن شايفين انه في السنه
الاخيره بالاخص مع اقامه هذه الحكومه في
عمليه تصعيد مستمره اولا بسبب تغيير سياسه
وزاره الدفاع هناك وزير الدفاع جديد يؤمن
بانه يجب اجتثاف اي محاوله لمعارضه
الاحتلال ومن الناحيه الثانيه نحن نرى
تصعيد مثل
حضرتك طبعا تفضلت واتحدث عنهم قبل
نحن نرى بان المجتمع الفلسطيني بدا يدرك
بانه يجب ان يقاوم لكي يتصدى لهذه الحكومه
لانه لا توجد امكانيات اخرى
لمعالجه هذا الوضع سوى التصدي ومن الناحيه
الثانيه نحن نرى بان حماس يريد بشكل او
باخر تقويه مكانته في الضفه الغربيه ونقل
المقاومه الى الضفه الغربيه وكل هذه
الامور تجتمع لتغيير مفاهيم العمل
الفلسطيني امام الاحتلال يعني ان يفشل جيش
الاحتلال في القبض على المطلوب كما يسمونه
بسبب مقاومه
ضاريه هل يمكن ان يتم استخلاص دروس معينه
من كل ذلك
بشكل عام في عده مناطق في الضفه الغربيه
التي هي عمليه فيها مقاومه اشد للاحتلال
وراينا هذا التصدي مثلا في جنين في طوباس
في اماكن معينه في نابلس في حواره
وهناك عمليه انتقال لهذا النمط من
العمليات من منطقه الى اخرى هناك عمليه
تقليد وطبعا هناك انتشار اولا للسلاح على
ما يبدو كمان في هناك دعم ايراني رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو صرح
بان ايران تقف وراء كل هذه العمليات يعني
امور مختلفه
اضافه الى التصعيد الذي تقوم بهذه الحكومه
ادت الى تغيير المفاهيم في الشارع
الفلسطيني وبضروره مقاومه الاحتلال بشكل
اخر يختلف عن ما كان حتى هذه الفتره
واضافه لكل هذا طبعا ضعف السلطه
الفلسطينيه وعدم قدرتها على حمايه
المواطنين الفلسطينيين الدكتور بريكس تبقى
معنا في نفس
لكن هذه المره في وجه اخر حيث جرى سجال
بين رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو ووزير الامن القومي يتمر بن كثير
اذ اعلن ابن كثير عن تقليص زيارات اهالي
الاسرى الفلسطينيين الى مره كل شهرين بدل
مره كل شهر ثم قال ديوان نتنياهو انه لم
يتم اتخاذ قرارا بتقليص زيارات الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وانما اذيع في هذا الشان هو
مجرد اخبار كاذبه ليعود بن كثير ويعلن ان
القرار اتخذ بل وتم ابلاغ مصلحه السجون به
ووضع قيد التنفيذ
منذ توليه منصبه وزيرا للامن القومي
الاسرائيلي نهايه العام الماضي لم تتوقف
حمله اتمار بن جفير المنتمي لاقصى اليمين
للتنكيل بالاسرى الفلسطينيين وتحويل
حياتهم الى جحيم كما سبق ان صرح بذلك
البدايه كانت في فبراير الماضي مع تحديد
كميه المياه المسموح للاسير باستخدامها
يوميا لاحتياجاته الطبيعيه وقطع المياه
الساخنه عن الاسرع وتقليص فتره الاستحمام
بحيث يكون لكل 120 اسيرا ساعه واحده يوميا
فقط كما صدق الكنيست الاسرائيلي في ذات
الشهر بقراءه اولى على مشروع قانون يهدف
الى حرمان الاسرى الفلسطينيين من حقهم
بالعلاج واجرائه عمليات جراحيه في مارس
الماضي بدات بعض ادارات السجون بتوجيهات
من
مضاعفه عمليات الاقتحام والتفتيش لزنازين
مستخدمه القنابل الصوتيه والكلاب
البوليسيه كما اصبحت تزود الاسرى بخبز
رديء ومجمد وفي يونيو الماضي وقعت مفوضه
السجون كاتابيري باعاز من بنكفير قرارا
يفرض على الاسرى تكاليف علاج الاسنان
المقدم لهم في المعتقل وفي نهايه يوليو
الماضي اغلق اي عمل في الافراج عن اسرى
فلسطينيين قبل انتهاء محكومياتهم حتى لو
كانوا على مشارف الموت بعد ادخاله تعديلات
على قانون الافراج المبكر وفي اليوم الاول
من سبتمبر قرر بن جفير تقليص زيارات
العائلات الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
لابنائها في سجون الاحتلال من مره كل شهر
الى مره كل شهرين
وسبق لبن كثير ان طرح مشاريع قوانينا
لاعدام الاسرى وسحب جنسيات اسرى الداخل من
فلسطينيين ثمانيه واربعين واقامات الاسرى
المقدسيين
نعود لك الدكتور سليم بريك هل ستكون
الغلبه في المياه في النهايه لبن كثير في
هذا الموضوع
لا باعتقادي انه في نهايه المطاف من سيقرر
هو بنيامين نتنياهو رئيس الحكومه
والكابينات الامني يعني اذا ممكن نرجع
لقضيه
قضيه زياره اهالي الاسرى الحد سنه 2014
كانت الزيارات كل اسبوعين بسته 2014 تقرر
من ناحيه المبدا ان يكون كل شهرين ولكن
كان هناك اتفاق بين مصلحه السجون من ناحيه
المسؤولين العسكريين في مناطق الضفه
الغربيه والاستخبارات والصليب الاحمر من
ناحيه اخرى ان يكون عمليا زيارات كل شهر
وليس كل شهرين مع ان الامر موجود من ناحيه
الشكليه وكان الزيارات يجب ان تكون كل
شهرين وعلى هذا الاساس استمرت الامور الان
نتحدث عن تغييرات يقوم بها بنج فير احاديه
الجانب التي لها تاثير على وزاره الدفاع
يعني كل ما ممكن ان يحدث كل الامور التي
اتفاقم الذي ممكن ان يحدث في الضفه
الغربيه هذا يتعلق ايضا بوزاره الدفاع
وهذا يعيدنا الى تركي هذه الحكومه الحكومه
منقسمه لقسمين بشكل عام بين يمين نتنياهو
ومسؤول الامن القومي وقياده الجيش
والاستخبارات يريدون عدم التصعيد في الضفه
الغربيه وخفض حده التوتر ومن الناحيه
الثانيه بنك فيروس اتخذوا استراتيجيه
التصعيد والتنكيل بالفلسطينيين وعلى هذا
الاساس تقوم هناك
المشدات بين الجانبين نتنياهو وجد حل بعدم
التئام الكابينات كطريقه للالتفاف حول هذا
الموضوع الان يجب ان نفهم ان بينجبير ايضا
له اعتبارات شخصيه حزبيه في هذا الموضوع
يعني هو يكره العرب ويكره الفلسطينيين
كسياسه ولكن هذه لا يمكن ان تكون سياسه
بالمفهوم
الكامل للكلمه اتخاذ قرارات يجب ان يكون
بالتنسيق مع اجهزه الامن والان نحن نرى ان
اجهزه الامن قد خرجت وبشكل علني ضد بنج
فير بما في ذلك مجلس الامن القومي الجهاز
الشباك واجهزه اخرى تقول بان بن جير عمليا
يسك ب الزيت على النار وبهذا هو يشكل خطر
ايضا على مواطنيه دوله اسرائيل الان هناك
نقطه مهمه اضافيه ان شهر ايلول القادم لحد
بدايه اكتوبر عمليا هناك اعياد اليهود هل
راس السنه
ويوم الغفران والى اخره هل اسرائيل تريد
هذا التصعيد في هذه الفتره انا لا اعتقد
ان هذا ما تريده شكرا لك يا دكتور سليم
بريك على هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
في المشهد الاوكراني وفي تطور غير مسبوق
منذ بدايه الحرب يتزامن مع عزم كياب
توجيهه ضربات الى العمق الروسي اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده اختبرت بنجاح صواريخ محليه الصنع
يبلغ مداها الف كيلو متر
اوكرانيا اجرت تجربه ناجحه لصاروخ اصاب
هدفا في قلب مدينه دانيتسك الرئيس
الاوكراني فولو دوميرسي قال على قناته على
التليجرام ان الصاروخ اصاب هدفه على بعد
700 كيلومتر الاعلان هذا قد يعني ان
الصاروخ انطلق على الاغلب من منطقه ما من
الضواحي الشماليه الغربيه لكياف بقياس
المسافه القصوى التي قطعها الصاروخ قبل
اصابه الهدف والمعلومه يمكن ان تدفع
للاستنتاج ان هذا الصاروخ يمكن ان يصيب
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو على اعتبار ابعد
نقطه اطلاق في العمق الاوكراني فان
الصاروخ يمكن ان ينطلق من ضواحي كييف او
مناطق في شمله شرقي اوكرانيا
مستشار الامن القومي الاوكراني اوليكس
داني لوف قال ان برنامج تطوير الصواريخ في
اوكرانيا بدا قبل ثلاث سنوات كياف كثفت
منذ حرب روسيا جهودها لتوطين التصنيع
العسكري شركه الدفاع البريطانيه
اعلنت عزمها انشاء ذراع تصنيع في اوكرانيا
وتتضمن الخطه انتاج اسلحه مدفعيه خفيفه من
عيار
وخمسه مليمترات واعلنت شركه اسلحه باسم
دروع اوكرانيا استئناف انتاج مدافع هاون
وانها سلمت المئات منها بالفعل للجيش
الاوكراني
اضافه لانتاج قذائف هارون عيار 60 و82
و120 ملم
ونشرت وسائل اعلام روسيه تقارير تفيد بان
شركه بايكار التركيه تعمل على اكمال بناء
مصنع طائرات سياره في اوكرانيا ليكون
جاهزا للتصنيع عام
وستستخدم بايكار الشركه المصنعه لمسيره
بيرقدار محركات منتجه في اوكرانيا
وتتهم موسكو
بتصنيع زوارق مسيره وقالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه منتصف الشهر الماضي ان قواتها
استهدفت مراكز انتاج وتخزين قوارب مسيره
في اوديسا
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني والمتحدث باسمي وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه يوريساك قال ان بلاده
تعمل على تطوير قاعده
لصناعتها العسكريه
نحن فخرون باننا نستطيع بنجاح اختبار
صواريخ في الحقيقه مداها الف كيلو متر لكن
الاختبارات كانت لمدى 700 كيلومتر فقط وهو
جزء من برنامج صواريخ طويله المدى ونعمل
على اطلاق الانتاج الجماعي لها في اقرب
وقت تحت رعايه رئيس الجمهوريه وزاره
الدفاع وهو سيكون انجازا مهما لاوكرانيا
طبعا في الوقت الذي نتلقى فيه بكل امتنان
دعم حلفائنا العسكري لكننا في ذات الوقت
نطور قاعده صناعاتنا العسكريه فلدينا
سياره ننتجها ولدينا برنامج الصواريخ
بعيده المدى ونامل ان نحقق اكتفاء ذاتيا
في المستقبل
وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق اهلا وسهلا
بك هذا التطوير للصناعه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه هل يمكن ان يؤثر في مجرى
المعارك
بالتاكيد نحن في الحقيقه نرى
تقدما كبيرا من حيث تطوير اوكرانيا
لقدراتها
الصواريخ
والصواريخ البلاستيكيه والصواريخ الجوال
والمسير سيارات الجو الطائرات
ومسيرات القوارب ولها تاثير كبير في
المعارك ونتوقع ان هذا التاثير سيزداد في
المستقبل القريب تطوير الصواريخ باليستيه
يصل مداها الف كيلو متر ويمكن ان تضرب
العمق الروسي هل يعني ان لا تريد ان تعول
على الغرب في مثل هذا النوع من الاسلحه
هناك اتفاق غير مكتوب
والتزامات من الجانب الاوكراني بان
اوكرانيا لن تستخدم
المعدات المصنعه في الغرب او المزوده من
قبل الغرب لتوجيه ضربات ضد الاراضي
الروسيه نحن نتحدث عن الحدود الروسيه
المعترف بها دوليا لكن ذلك لا يتضمن شبه
جزيره القرم او الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
روسيا ضمتها مؤخرا اوكرانيا تحاول تطوير
اسلحتها طويله المدى
والحلفاء الغربيون شد قالوا انهم لا
يشجعون اوكرانيا على ذلك ولا يسهلنا لها
الامر لعمل ذلك الموقف الامريكي مثلا اكد
على ذلك هل يمكن ان تذهب وحيده في ضرب
العمق الروسي دون موافقه امريكيه وغربيه
اوكرانيا هي دوله ذات السياده
واوكرانيا لا تطلب موافقه حول ما تختاره
من اهداف وايضا
الدينار نقاد القوات الاوكرانيه الشهر
اكثر من مره ان اوكرانيا لم تطلب من احد
موافقته على اي شيء لان هذه الحرب حربنا
وما طالبت به اوكرانيا هو ان تزود بصواريخ
طويله المدى لضرب الاهداف الروسيه داخل
الاراضي المحتله لكن اما عن الطريقه التي
ستدير بها اوكرانيا الحرب طبعا هناك قيود
على مدى التنسيق بيننا وبين حلفائنا
الغربيين كيف تطمح لي تحقيق اكتفاء ذاتي
في الصناعه العسكريه هل هذا
قريب
لا اعتقد ان الامر كذلك
ولا ادري
هناك
بلدان قليله في العالم مثل كوريا الشماليه
التي يمكن ان تقول انها لديها اكتفاء ذاتي
في صناعاتي الحربيه لكن في بقيه انحاء
العالم ربما كل البلدان حتى
حتى روسيا تعتمد على التعاون الدولي وعلى
الحصول على قطع غيار واوكرانيا لم يكن
لديها ذلك الطموح لان يكون لديها اكتفاء
ذاتي كامل هناك بعض الامور او العناصر
التي هي حيويه او ضروريه مثل الذخائر
والصواريخ على اوكرانيا ان تحاول انتاجها
داخل البلد شكرا جزيلا لك يا مساعد وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه سابق اوليسكي
في المقابل اكد يوري بوريسوف مدير وكاله
الفضاء الروسيه روس كوسموس وضع منظومه
صواريخ الاستراتيجيه العابره للقارات في
الخدمه القتاليه المزيد عن هذه المنظومه
عند اجراء اول تجربه لصاروخ الصرمات
البلاستي في ابريل الماضي قال الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان هذا الصاروخ
سيجعل اعداء روسيا يتوقفون ويفكرون
الصاروخ الذي وصفه بوتين بان لا مثيل له
ولن يكون له مثيل يزن 220 طنا ويبلغ طوله
اكثر من 35 مترا
يتراوح مداه بين عشره الاف وثمانيه عشر
الف كيلو متر ما يجعله قادرا على ضرب اي
بقعه في الارض يستطيع حمل عشره رؤوس نوويه
ويمكنه اطلاق حموله قصوى تبلغ 50 ميجا طن
من ماده تي ان تي صممت صاروخ سامات
الافلاتي من انظمه الدفاع المضاده
للصواريخ من خلال تقنيه لا تمنح هذه
الانظمه الا وقتا قصيرا لبدء التتبع
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوتها نفذت 5 ضربات دقيقه ادت الى تعطيل
نظام التحكم الالكتروني الاستراتيجي للجيش
الاوكراني واضافه الوزاره ان القوات
الروسيه تدمرت ورشات لتجميع المسيرات
البحريه المستخدمه من قبل كياب لشن هجمات
على الاراضي الروسيه
اكد عمده موسكو اسقاط مسيره قرب المدينه
بينما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تدمير
طائره مسيره اخرى في مقاطعه موسكو من جهته
قال حكموا منطقه كورسك الروسيه ان مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين هاجمت مدينه
كوردشاتوف فجر اليوم وفي مقاطعه بريان قال
الحرس الوطني الروسي انه اسقط ثلاث طائرات
مسيره فوق المقاطعه كما اعلنت سلطات
مقاطعه
مسيره صباح هذا اليوم فوق المقاطعه دون
تسجيل اضرار او خسائر
ودعا عمده العاصمه الروسيه موسكو سيرجيو
الى توسيع الدفاعات الجويه في المدينه
لمواجهه الارتفاع الملحوظ في هجمات
الطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه وفاد سميانين
بنصب منظومات الدفاع جويا جديده في
الاسابيع الاخيره في مناطق مختلفه من اجل
حمايه المدينه
ومن موسكو اندريه ينضم الينا وهو المحلل
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا بيك سيد
هذا الحرص من موسكو على تطوير انظمه دفاع
ضد المسيرات الاوكرانيه الى اي مدى يعكس
قلق روسي فعلا من المسيرات الاوكرانيه
يصف قوس
التهديدات الجويه الاتيه من الجانب
الاوكراني يبدو انها تشكل خطرا محتملا
كبيرا لان
الاوكرانيون يستخدمون المسيرات
وقنابل انتحاريه ضد عدد من الاهداف بما في
ذلك موسكو العاصمه لهذا السبب روسيا تحاول
في مناطق موسكو وبريانسكو
تعزيز الدفاعاتها الجويه للتصدي للهجمات
الاوكرانيه اذا من هذه الناحيه لا يوجد
فرق في التصدي
لصواريخ او للسيارات الجويه او اي انواع
اخرى من الاسلحه الهجوميه وهل ستكون هذه
المهمه سهله خاصه وان بدات في تطوير انتاج
مسيرات محليه
مستوى
وايضا من ناحيه الكم والكيف
للسيارات الاوكرانيه لا تشكل تهديدا
حقيقيا لروسيا لان روسيا اثبتت قدرتها على
التصدي لمعظمي
المسيرات واسقاطها للاسف الجانب الاوكراني
يستخدم
معدات من
البلدان الغربيه
لضرب اهداف روسيا في منطقه بسكوف وغيرها
بعيدا عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه نعم هذا يشكل
مشكله لكن اذا ما عدنا الى الوراء
لراينا ان قدره الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
قد زادت من حيث
القدره والكم والنوع لانظمه الدفاع
الروسيه قرب الحدود الاوكرانيه وماذا عن
القدره الروسيه في التصدي لصواريخ
باليستيه بعد ان جربت كييف صواريخ تصل
مداها الى الف
اولا هذا نوع من الدعايه الاوكرانيه لان
اوكرانيا حتى قبل العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
كان لديها
مواقع اختبار
للصواريخ بعيده
المدى لهذا السبب لا اعتقد ان
مدى الحقيقي ليس الف كيلو متر لكن على ايه
حال روسيا قادره على كشف هذه الصواريخ
البالستيه وكروز الجواله وتدميرها شكرا
جزيلا لك
من موسكو
[موسيقى]
الان الى التطورات في النيجر حيث اعلنت
وزاره الداخليه التابعه للمجلس العسكري ان
وضع السفير الفرنسي وزوجته غير قانونيه
وقالت ان الاوامر صدرت للجهات المختصه
لتنفيذ قرار الترحيلهما من البلاد ياتي
ذلك فيما اكد الرئيس الفرنسي انه يجري
مباحثات بشكل يومي مع رئيس النيجر المعتز
محمد بازوم مشددا على ان اي قرارات
ستتخذها باريس بشان النيجر ستكون بناء على
المباحثات مع الرئيس بازون ياتي ذلك في
وقت خرجت فيه مظاهرات امام القاعده
العسكريه الفرنسيه في مطار النيامي
للمطالبه بخروج القوات الفرنسيه من البلاد
يسود الهدوء المشوي بالحذر والقلق النيجر
بعد اكثر من شهر على الانقلاب العسكري
هناك
الانقلابيون ماضون في تكريس سلطاتهم وبدت
سيما ذلك واضحه في مختلف المفاصل ومع
اصرار السلطات العسكريه على طرد السفير
الفرنسي من البلاد مددت الجمعه بتصريحات
الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون التي اكد فيها ان
السفيره باق في منصبه رغما عن قاده
الانقلاب ووصفت حكومه الانقلاب تصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي بانها تدخل صارخ في شؤون
النيجر هدفه ادامه علاقه الراعي والعميل
باي ثمن واتهمت ماكرون باستغلال مجموعه
اكواس ومحاوله اجبارها على انشاء ما وصفته
بالمشروع الاستعماري
رفض الوجود الفرنسي في النيجر اخذ في
الاتساع براي كثيرين ودعت الجبهه الوطنيه
وهي كيان شعبي تشكل بعد الانقلاب
المواطنين الى المشاركه يوم السبت في
مسيره كبرى يليها اعتصام بالقرب من
القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه في ميامي
ويتواصل الى حين رحيل الجنود الفرنسيين عن
البلاد بينما حذرت فرنسا من مغبه اي عمل
يستهدف سفارتها او قاعدتها العسكريه وهددت
بالرد وفي غمره هذه الظروف ينتظر كثيرون
خطوات مجموعه اكواس القادمه وقد هددت
بالتدخل العسكري لاعاده النظام الدستوري
في البلاد خاصه وان المجموعه نفت الانباء
المتداوله بشان اقتراحها مرحله انتقاليه
في النيجر مدتها تسعه اشهر تسلم بعدها
السلطه للمدنيين كما جرى من في نيجيريا
وقالت المجموعه ان رؤيتها بشان الوضع في
النيجر واضحه وتنص على استعاده النظام
الدستوري فورا واطلاق سراح الرئيس محمد
بازوم واعادته الى منصبه في هذه الاثناء
بدات السلطات العسكريه وكانها تتحسب لاي
تطورات فقد اعلنت مؤقتا حظر انشطه وتحركات
المنظمات الدوليه والمنظمات غير الحكوميه
الوطنيه وجميع وكالات الامم المتحده فيما
سمته مناطق العمليات العسكريه في البلاد
ليبقى الموقف في النيجر متوترا حافلا
بالتطورات في انتظار تسويه مؤقته او دائمه
تبدو صعبه للغايه حتى الان
قد قال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكيه جونغكوربي ان واشنطن ما تزال
ترى مجالا للحلول الدبلوماسيه بشان انقلاب
الناشر واكد كرب مواصله السعي الى حلول
الدبلوماسيه لضمان احترام المؤسسات
الديمقراطيه في كل من الغابون والنيجر
اسماعيل ولد الشيخ سيديه الكاتب والمحلل
المختص في الشارع الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا بك
هذه المناكفه المستمره بين فرنسا والنيجر
كيف يمكن ان تنتهي
اهلا بك سيدي الكريم محمد اهلا بمشاهدك
الكرام اعتقد
ان السفير السفير الفرنسي هو مجرد قشه قد
يكتب لها ان تقسم ظهر البعير لانه ما لقاه
لم يلاقيه السفر نيجيريا التي هي راس
الحربه والرئيس الدوري للاكواس ولم يلا
على الاقل اللي هو يعني
يحاذي النيجر
ويحاد
المجموعه العسكريه الحاكمه الان بعيدا عن
السفير ليفواري والسفير السنغالي اللذان
يحلواني ونيجيري النعل من هنا يمكن ان
نقول ان السفير وملفه وملفه حصانته وملفه
طرده لطرده وقطع الكهرباء والماء عنه وهو
قنبله موقوته
وذريعه قد تستظهروا فرنسا
بالاستغاثه المفترضه من رئيس الوزراء
المقيم في باريس رئيس الوزراء الاسبق رئيس
وزراء بازون
لكي تتخذ خطوه قد تكون بدايه لعمل عسكري
منظم ومنسق مع الاكواس لان فرنسا لا
تعوزها الاسباب لكن يعوزها الظهير
الافريقي لكي لا تظهر بمظهر القوه الغاشمه
لكنها لن تظن
باي شيء قد يحقق السياسه المعلنه على
الاقل وهي الاطاحه بالعسكر واعاده بازو
صحيح يعني
عفوا سيد اسماعيل هل يمكن ان يكون هذا هو
ما يخوض فيه الان الرئيس ماكرون مع بازوم
وقد قال انه على اتصال يوميا به
لكل كل يوم هو في شان منذ 26 ابريل مره
يقطع عنه الماء والكهرباء والاتصال
الخارجي ومره يتصل لكن لكن
ليس احسن منه ضربا من الناحيه السياسيه
لان المبادره الجزائريه لم تاتي من فراغ
وقد تقطع الحبال في ايديها لان الجزائر
دوله جاره للنيجر وحليفه في الاتحاد
الافريقي لنيجيريا ولم تنطلق من فراغ في
سته اشهر المعلنين للفتره الانتقاليه
المحتمله التي سيتفاوض عليها وقد لا يكون
حديث الرئيس نيجيريا امام العلماء البارحه
زلت اللسان بحيث اسقط الفتره الانتقاليه
الانتقادها جنرال عبد السلام ابو بكر في
نيجيريا على ما قد سيكون
في النيجر وبالتالي رغم رسميا
بان هذا الكلام هو كلامه للايكواس لكن
بالمقابل ماكرون اعتقد انه لن يضل
بمظلييه الموجودين في النجمه ولن يضيع
فرصه مضايقه السفير تفوت من غير
اتخاذها مطيه او سببا لما قد يكون من
عمليه حتى ولو كانت خاطفه وانيقه وجميله
لتخليص الرئيس بازون ومن ثم فتح
المفاوضاتهم الرئيس بازو نفسه هو اكبر
ورقه لدى العسكريه شكرا جزيلا لك اسماعيل
ولد الشيخ سيديه من نواكشوط
[موسيقى]
نقلت وكاله نبان فرنسيه عن قائد المرحله
الانتقاليه في الجابون الجنرال بريس
اوليجما القول انه يتعهد باقامه مؤسسات
اكثر ديمقراطيه في البلاد وكانت مجموعه
دول وسط افريقيا المعروفه اختصارا باكاس
قد طالبت قاده الانقلاب في الجابون باعاده
النظام الدستوري وضمان سلامه الرئيس
المحتز علي بونجو كما كلفت رئيس دوله
افريقيا الوسطى بالوساطه للخروج من الازمه
الراهنه
تبدو الحياه الطبيعيه تتخللها احيانا
مظاهرات داعمه للانقلابيين بهتاف مكرر قضي
الامر والامر هنا انتهاء حقبه حكم ال
بونجو الذي دام 56 عاما من الاب الى الابن
المحتجز والذي احاله العسكر الى التقاعد
لكن ما يجري ليس عاديا وبلا تبعات داخليه
واقليميه وخارجيه بينما يحضر قاده
الانقلاب لمراسم تنصيب قائد الحرس
الجمهوري ادريس اوليج رئيسا للمرحله
الانتقاليه تطالب المعارضه بتسليمها
السلطه وهذا الرجل مرشح المعارضه في
الانتخابات الاخيره المثيره للجدل
يقول انه الاحق بحكم البلاد في مقابله مع
محطه فرنسيه رفض وصف مجر الاربعاء بانقلاب
بالامتداد لحكم عائله بونجو على حد زعمه
لقد قررت عائله بونجو ان يتنحى الرئيس
جانبا وان يستمر النظام القائم بشكل فعال
لذلك وضع جيما في الواجهه نحن نعلم من يقف
خلفه وعلى هذا الاساس لا يزال نظام بانجو
على قيد الحياه بنبره اكثره هدوءا خاطب
المتحدث باسم تحالف المعارضه الغابونيه
المجلس العسكري الحاكم دعاه الى التشاور
والاتفاق على اطار وطني ومسؤول للخروج من
الوضع الحالي استمرار حظر التجوال واغلاق
الحدود اثر سلبا على مدينه انبا الحدوديه
في الكاميرون شلت فيها حركه التجاره على
امل الا يدوم هذا الحال كثيرا هل تحرك
وساطه دوله افريقيا الوسطى المياه الراكده
وسط امال ضئيله لاستجابه العسكري لمطالب
مجلس السلم والامن في الاتحاد الافريقي
ستبدا تلك الوساطه تشمل المطالب المستبعد
تحقيقها على الاقل على المدى عوده الجيش
فورا الى سكناته واعاده السلطه دون شروط
الى المدنيين وايضا الافراج عن الرئيس
بونجو وافراد اسرته واضائح حكومته
المحتجزين ضروره اجراء انتخابات حره
ونزيهه تحت رقابه الاتحاد الافريقي من
المبكر التكهن بنتائج الاجتماع الاستثنائي
لمجموعه ايكاس والمقرر الاثنين المقبل اي
في نفس اليوم الذي سيؤدي فيه اوليجين جيما
اليمين الدستوريه في القصر الرئاسي رئيسا
للمرحله الانتقاليه التي لا تعرف مدتها ما
هو جليا العيان من الان ومن كل ما جرى هي
الصفعه الاخرى التي تلقتها فرنسا في
مستعمرتها السابقه في وقت قياسي تراجع
نفوذها عنوه في القاره الافريقيه واسترفض
شعبي لوجودها في المنطقه جدو العسكر على
راس السلطه اتباعا من بلد الى اخر قد لا
يكون خاتمه احزان شعوب قاره غنيه
افقرتها انظمه لا تعترف بالحكم الرشيد
وتلقى الدعم من دول غربيه مقابل مصالح
ضيقه
[موسيقى]
قالت خدمه الاطفال اليونانيه انه تم ارسال
اكثر من 100 رجل اطفاء اضافي الى منطقه
افراز بشمال شرق البلاد تدعمهم عشر طائرات
وسبع مروحيات من تسع دول اوروبيه مع
استمرار الحرائق في المنطقه لليوم الرابع
عشر على التوالي وقد طلبت السلطات
اليونانيه من سكان المنطقه الاستعداد
لاجلاء محتمل ومنذ اندلاعها في التاسع عشر
من الشهر الماضي دمرت الحرائق منازل
ومساحه واسعه من الغابات في منطقتين
بالقرب من الحدود التركيه
ولكن لماذا اشتدت حرائق الغابات في
اليونان هذا العام في شهر اغسطس اب وكيف
تعزوها الحكومه الى التغير المناخي محمود
الكن يشرح لنا كيف تتكون ما تعرف بعلبه
الاشعال داخل الغابات نتيجه ارتفاع درجات
الحراره لتزيد من وتيره الحرائق
ارتفاعه معدلي درجه حراره الارض يزيد من
وتيره المناخ القاسي وكذلك من وتيره
الموجات الحاره لحدوث حرائق الغابات
وانتشارها هناك عده عوامل متداخله هذه
العوامل هي الحراره العاليه يضاف اليها
ايضا الرطوبه
المنخفضه ومن العوامل كذلك النباتات
الجافه
ومنها ايضا الرياح السريعه
وبالتاكيد غياب المطر هذه مجتمعه ستكون
صندوق الاشعال او ما يعرف بين القبه
الحراريه لكن كيف ذلك عندما تاتي موجه
حاره اعلى من المعدل المعتاد يسخن سطح
الارض ويسخن الهواء الملامس للسطح هذا
الهواء الساخن يصعد للاعلى لكن الهواء في
الطبقه العليا له ضغط اعلى من الهواء
الصاعد الساخن
ويضغطه نحو الاسفل بهذه الحركه تتبدد
السحب ضمن هذه الفقاعه وتتعرض الارض
للمزيد من اشعه الشمس فتزداد الحراره
هذا يؤدي الى انخفاض الرطوبه في الجو
وكذلك داخل النباتات عند وصول نسبه
الرطوبه داخل الاشجار الى اقل من 30%
تتحول الى وقود جاه
اكتملت الان عناصر علبه الاشعال اللازمه
وهي بحاجه الى شراره نحو 90% من الشراري
ياتي بسبب نشاطات الانسان سواء كانت نارا
للتدفئه او للاشتواء في المخيمات او اقابا
للسجائر او اسلاك كهربائي مقطوعه اما
الباقي فياتي من عوامل طبيعيه كالبرق
والحمم البركانيه بعد الشراره تشتعل
الاشجار في هذه الفقاعه الان ياتي دور
الرياح القويه ليزيد الطين بالله او
بالاصح ليزيد من مساحه الاشتعال فينقل
النيران من منطقه الى اخرى
التضاريس قد تؤدي دورا كذلك في نقل
النيران فالنيران تنتقل اسرع الى اعلى
الجبل في حين تكون ابطا الى الاسفل وكلما
زادت مساحه الحريق صعدت السيطره عليه
[موسيقى]
في اجواء استقطاب دولين صارت افريقيا محور
تنافس بين القوه الكبرى تمت تهافت على
القاره الافريقيه من عواصم القوه الكبرى
تحدثنا في السابق عن اعتبارات امنيه وجيو
استراتيجيه لكن ماذا عن الثروات وما الذي
يميز فعلا القاره السمراء افريقيا هي ثاني
اكبر قارات العالم من حيث المساحه وعدد
السكان وتاتي في المرتبه الثانيه بعد قاره
اسيا تبلغ مساحتها اكثر من 30 مليون
كيلومتر مربع طبعا يحد القاره من الشمال
البحر الابيض المتوسط تحدها قناه السويس
والبحر الاحمر من جهه الشمال الشرقي بينما
يحدها المحيط الهندي من الشرق والجنوب
الشرقي والمحيط الاطلسي من الغرب تمتلك
افريقيا نحو 60% من مساحه الاراضي الصالحه
للزراعه في العالم وتمثل حرفه الزراعه
والري ثمانين بالمئه الحرف الموجوده لدى
شعوب القاره بالاضافه الى العمل في
الغابات والثروه الطبيعيه ووفقا للامم
المتحده فان افريقيا موطن لنحو ثمانيه
بالمئه من احتياطات الغاز الطبيعي في
العالم كما تمتلك القاره ثلث مجموع
المعادن في العالم وتمتلك دول افريقيا نحو
نصف احتياطي الذهب في العالم تمت امثله
مهمه في النيجر مثلا التي شهدت انقلابا
عسكريا مؤخرا هي سابع اكبر منتج
لليورانيوم في العالم واليورانيوم هو
الوقود الاكثر استخداما للطاقه النوويه
كما انه يستخدم في علاج السرطان
سجلات التاريخ تشير الى انه في اواخر
القرن التاسع عشر اشتركت القوى الكبرى
انذاك في حمله تزاحما واحتلت معظم القاره
الافريقيه وتحولت العديد من البلدان الى
دول محتله تحدثنا عن الثروات فكيف حاله
صاحبه الثروات افريقيا هي القاره الافقر
في العالم على الرغم من انها القاره
الاغنى في العالم بثرواتها الطبيعيه لا
تزال افريقيا الاقليم الاشده تضررا من
ازمه الجوع في العالم حيث ان واحدا من كل
خمسه اشخاص يعاني الجوع في هذه القاره اي
اكثر من ضعف المتوسط العالمي
وطبقا لتقديرات اطلقها برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في ربيع عام 2022 تم رصد معاناه
اكثر او نحو ثلاثه عشر مليون افريقي من
اخطار المجاعه يتركزون في شرق القاره بشكل
خاص ولكن مع خريف العام نفسه ارتفع العدد
لالامس حاجز العشرين مليون نسمه
تنشا اكبر معدلات الوفيات في افريقيا من
امراض يمكن الوقايه منها وتتنقل بالخصوص
عن طريق المياه وهي امراض تؤثر على الرضع
والاطفال الصغار اكثر من اي فئه اخرى
والسبب الرئيسي وراء هذه الامراض هي ازمه
المياه الاقليميه
توترات عديده تشهدها قاره افريقيا
انقلابات واشتباكات ازمات عسكريه وسياسيه
فضلا عن زياده دائره العنف المرتبط بنشاط
الجماعات المسلحه للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من جوهانسبورغ البروفيسور
ديفيد مونيم الاستاذ بجماعه جونس والخبير
في الشؤون الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا بك
نسال ضيفنا
افريقيا القاره الاغنى وهي كذلك القاره
الافقر كيف نفسر ذلك
لاسباب عديده اعتقد
ان ما ينبغي ان يقال هو ان لدينا
عوامل محليه وخارجيه
هي تسببت في الوضع الحالي القائم على عدم
المساواه والفقر الذي شرحته
تاريخيا
يعود ذلك الى العبوديه ثم الاستعمار ثم
الاستعمار الجديد الذي حتى بعد استقلال
الدول الافريقيه
ما ان نلحظه في غرب افريقيا هو ان فرنسا
قوه استعماريه اخرى ما تزال متحكمه في
حياه الافارقه بشكل غير مباشر لكن من
المهم ايضا هناك ايضا
سوء الاداره
والحكم غير رشيد
ينبغي ان نكون
حريصين على ان نعمم في افريقيا هناك 55
بلدا
ومليار و300 مليون
وعبر القاره
الوضع يختلف من بلد الى اخر
والدول الفقيره هناك الفقيره وهناك الغنيه
جدا
هذه بعض العوامل
غنيه بالمعادن
وباراضيها الزراعيه
واتربتها الخصبه
[موسيقى]
وينبغي ان ننظر الى
يحتاج
ثلاث مرات حجم افريقيا
هو ثلاث مرات الولايات المتحده وهذا يعطي
فكره عن مدى اتساع هذه القاره
واراضيها الخصبه واعتقد ان هناك حاجه الى
ان يكون هناك حكم رشيد واداره جيده
للثروات
وشعبها هو الذي يمكن ان يفيدها اشرت الى
الاستعمار الجديد هل هو نتاج الاتفاقات
جرت قبل عقود بين المستعمر خاصه فرنسا قبل
ان تغادر دول عديده في افريقيا
هذه
الاتفاقيات تم توقيعها خلال بعد الاستقلال
في الستينات في ذلك الوقت كان هناك الحرب
البارده وكان هناك فرنسا التي كان لها
قواعد عسكريه في تلك البلدان
وسمحت لبعض الانظمه العنيفه والمستبد مثل
بوكاسا في افريقيا الوسطى
وزاير مع سيسيكو وعدد من
الانظمه المستبده التي حرمت شعوبها من
الحريه
لم يتم الاهتمام بالتعليم وهذا
قد اللقوا دعما من فرنسا
وعندما كان الناس شعوب تحاول ان تثور فان
فرنسا تضمن ان الدعم العسكري باسم
المساعده الخارجيه باسلحه
لاسكات وقمع مواطني تلك البلدان
ونحن نضع اللوم على فرنسا
الافارقه ايضا نوجه اليهم اللوم لانهم
كانوا في وخاصه النخبه السياسيه التي
سنحتها الفرصه للاستيلاء على
الاموال الاموال الفاسده ووضعها في البنوك
الاجنبيه
وكانوا يرسلون ابنائهم الى فرنسا
وفرنسا
كانت تطبق سياسه
تجعل الحكام
بمستوى الفرنسيين انفسهم دكتور البروفيسور
العسكر الذين استلموا مقاليد الامور في
اكثر من دوله يعيدون بتغيير هذا الواقع هل
يستطيعون
تاريخ
الانقلابات العسكريه سيء جدا
ليس من
المسلم انهم سيحققون ما يعيدون به الامر
ياخذ وقتا طويلا لنقل الحكم الى المدنيين
[موسيقى]
وينتهي الامر ببعضهم الى ان يصبحوا فاسدين
ايضا ويستولوا على ثروات البلد اذا السجل
يختلف من بلد الى اخر وبعض هؤلاء القاده
العسكريين مختلفون فيما يتعلق بغانا
والجون
اعتقد انه تمكن من ان ياخذ بلده كرئيس
عسكري الى الحكم المدني
وكذلك الى شيء من التنميه التي نراها في
غانا اليوم
اذا الامر يختلف بحسب طبيعه ونوعيه هؤلاء
العسكريين شكرا جزيلا لك
الاستاذ بجماعه الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
جنون الكره تعبير يتكرر كثيرا على السنه
المعلقين والمحللين والمتابعين لمنافسات
كره القدم في اشاره الى التحولات
والمفاجات التي تشهدها هذه المباراه او
تلك لكن يبدو ان لجنون الساحر المستديره
وجا اخر فبعد ساعه من الان بعد ساعه
بالضبط من الان سيغلق موسم الانتقالات
الصيفي في اوروبا او ما يطلق عليه
الميركات الصيفي بالطبع لا يمكن رصد رقم
معين حجم الاستثمارات في موسم الانتقالات
هذه لان الساعه المقبله ربما ربما تحمل
المزيد من الصفقات لكن المؤكده ان سوق
الانتقالات تقدر بمئات الملايين من
الدولارات تم من يرى ان حجم الصفقات تجاوز
ما هو معقول وان اطراف المعادله الكرويه
تبالغ في قيمه اللاعبين لكن المؤكد وهذه
وجهه نظر اخرى في فريق
المتابعين للكره ان كره القدم تجاوزت ومن
سنوات مربع الرياضه او التسليه والترفيه
لتصبح صناعه ومنظومه تجاريه دفعت اصحاب
المال الى الاستثمار فيها وبقوه لم تعد
المنافسه داخل الملعب فقط بل خارجه كذلك
بعد ساعه ربما تلتقون مع فريق النشره
الرياضيه ويمدكم باخر التطورات في هذا
الشان تحديدا ختام الحصاد في امان الله
[موسيقى]